WASHINGTON.
YOU ARE IN THE "CNN NEWSROOM" ON
THIS SATURDAY.
IT IS JUST AFTER 3:00 A.M. IN
KYIV, AND I WANT TO SHOW YOU
SOME OF THE MOST OMINOUS SIGHTS
SO FAR THIS EVENING.
TWO MASSIVE EXPLOSIONS WITHIN
SIDE OF OUR CNN CREWS AND THE
CAPITAL OF KYIV.
THESE FLASHES OF LIGHT KEEP
GLOWING IN THE DISTANCE.
THE MAYOR OF THE TOWN WHERE THIS
HAPPENED ABOUT 18 MILES FROM THE
CENTER OF THE CAPITAL SAYS A
PETROLEUM STORAGE DEPOT WAS HIT.
THIS IS AN AREA THAT HAS A LARGE
MILITARY AIRFIELD AND MULTIPLE
FUEL TANKS.
QUOTING FROM THE MAYOR NOW, THE
ENEMY WANTS TO DESTROY
EVERYTHING AROUND, BUT HE WILL
NOT BE SUCCESSFUL.
OUR AIRFIELD WAS SHELLED AS
WELL, BUT WE GOT IT.
IT'S UNDER CONTROL OF UKRAINE.
THE MAYOR ADDING, THE NIGHT WILL
BE DIFFICULT HERE AS WELL IN
KYIV, BUT WE WILL STAND OUR
GROUND, AND WE WILL WIN BECAUSE
GOD IS WITH US.
CNN'S ALEX MARQUARDT REPORTED
FROM A ROOF TOOP JUST MOMENTS
AFTER A BLAST HIT.
>> SINCE THEN FOR THE PAST 7, 8
MINUTES THERE HAS BEEN THIS
PULSING GLOW IN THE DISTANCE.
YOU HAVE TO IMAGINE THAT IT IS
SOME KIND OF FIRE.
IT IS A VERY EERIE SCENE.
IT IS A LOCATION WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT EARLIER TODAY BECAUSE
THERE WAS A MISSILE OR A ROCKET
THAT HIT A RESIDENTIAL BUILDING
NEAR THAT AIRPORT.
>> AND HERE IS WHERE THINGS
STAND WITH THE WAR ENTERING A
FOURTH DAY.
RUSSIA'S INVASION IS HITTING,
QUOTE, STIFFER EXPECTED
RESISTANCE FROM THE UKRAINIAN
MILITARY.
THE RUSSIANS ARE ALSO SUFFERING
HEAVIER LOSSES IN PERSONNEL AND
AIRCRAFT THAN EXPECTED AND FACE
UNEXPECTED DIFFICULTIES
SUPPLYING THEIR FORCES.
A SENIOR DEFENSE OFFICIAL SAYS
UKRAINIAN AIR DEFENSES HAVE
PERFORMED BETTER THAN
ANTICIPATED IN PREINVASION U.S.
INTELLIGENCE ASSESSMENTS.
AND RUSSIA HAS YET TO ESTABLISH
AIR SUPREMACY OVER UKRAINE.
UKRAINE NOW PLANS TO CLOSE ITS
BORDERS TO RUSSIA AND BELARUS
BEGINNING MONDAY.
ONLY UKRAINIAN CITIZENS WILL BE
ALLOWED TO CROSS FROM THOSE
COUNTRIES INTO UKRAINE.
A U.N. OFFICIAL TELLS CNN MORE
THAN 120,000 PEOPLE HAVE ESCAPED
UKRAINE SINCE THE ASSAULT BEGAN.
AND THERE ARE LINES AT A NUMBER
OF BORDER CROSSINGS.
POLAND SAYS 47,000 REFUGEES
CROSSED ITS BORDERS YESTERDAY
ALONE.
SO MUCH DESPERATION RIGHT NOW
TAKING PLACE THERE.
I WANT TO GO STRAIGHT TO CNN'S
MATTHEW CHANCE AT UKRAINE'S
CAPITAL CITY KYIV.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING THERE RIGHT
NOW, MATTHEW?
>> Reporter: WELL, A VERY TENSE
SITUATION AS YOU MIGHT EXPECT IN
THE UKRAINIAN CAPITAL BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, THE INTELLIGENCE
SUGGESTS AND WHAT UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS SUGGEST IS THAT
RUSSIAN FORCES ARE, YOU KNOW,
GATHERING THEIR STRENGTH AND
POISED TO AN ATTEMPT AN ASSAULT
ON THE CITY.
THOSE BIG FLASHES, THOSE GLOWS
YOU SAW ALEX REPORT ON EARLIER,
THEY'RE STILL TAKING PLACE TO A
LEZER EXTENT NOW.
BUT IN THE DISTANCE RIGHT BEHIND
ME THAT IS THE KYIV AREA,
THERE'S A STRATEGIC AIR BASE
LOCATED THERE.
AND THAT'S A LOCATION WHERE WE
BELIEVE RUSSIAN SPECIAL FORCES
WERE INITIALLY DEPLOYED, ONE OF
THE LOCATIONS.
THEY COULD HAVE USED TO BRING IN
MORE FORCES, MORE TROOPS, MORE
ARMOR IN ORDER TO SURROUND THE
CAPITAL AND STAGE THAT INVASION
OF THE UKRAINIAN CITY HERE OF
KYIV.
THAT DID NOT HAPPEN FOR WHATEVER
REASON.
CLEARLY THEY MET A GREAT DEAL OF
RESISTANCE ON THE GROUND.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHO IS IN CONTROL
OF THAT REGION RIGHT NOW.
BUT, YOU KNOW, AS THE MAYOR OF
THE -- OF THE LOCAL AREA SAID,
YOU KNOW, THOSE BIG FLARES WE
SAW LIGHTING UP THE SKY MOST
LIKELY TO BE FUEL TANKS, STORAGE
TANKS POSSIBLY BECAUSE OF THE
CLOSE BY AIR BASE THAT HAD BEEN
IGNITED.
CLEARLY THERE'S SOME SORT OF
CONFRONTATION UNDER WAY RIGHT
NOW.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO GO AND
LOOK BECAUSE THERE IS A CURFEW
IN PLACE IN THIS CITY, AND IT'S
NOT GOING TO BE LIFTED UNTIL
MONDAY MORNING.
SO WHOLE SUNDAY THERE'S GOING TO
BE A CURFEW AS WELL.
AND THAT'S A EARE FLEXION HOW
CONCERNED AUTHORITIES ARE HERE,
THAT WE'RE ON THE CUSP OF
SOMETHING VERY DAN